I almost died from a cough and this is
that story okay yeah there's no better
way to say this so one night June 2017 I
am masturbating in bed and I start
coughing up blood
I'm like have I ever coughed up blood
before no is this okay
probably not so i call 9-1-1 and they
send an ambulance one of the EMTs when
they're checking me out like presses on
my stomach and she's like is your
stomach always this distended I'm like
okay I don't have a beach bod right now
but like it's a little insulting I'm at
the ER and the doctor asked me like all
the standard questions and my smoker
have I been sick like what's been going
on and at the end of his questions he
asked me if there's anything I want to
tell him that I think might be relevant
I'm like okay there's no way that this
is related but I wasn't masturbating is
that part and he's like no there's no
way that has nothing to do with it but
he was very polite about it so they give
me an x-ray and let me go I'm walking
out of the hospital and the doctor comes
running out after me yelling my name
saying that the attending physician saw
my x-ray and wants to do a CT scan so
they do a CT scan they see a cloudy
patch on my lung and they decide to
quarantine me under the suspicion that I
have tuberculosis they keep me
quarantined in the ER for a few days
they run some tests the tests come back
negative I don't have tuberculosis so
they let me go I'm feeling good I go get
Popeye's for lunch cuz hey I'm alive and
Poppi's is delicious and then later that
afternoon I go to an open mic cuz I
hustle baby on the way to the open mic I
call my grandmother I'm very close with
my family and we didn't want to worry my
grandmother so I just wanted to call her
to let her know that yes I had been in
the hospital but I was okay and as I'm
on the phone with my grandmother I get
this rattling feeling in my chest and I
start coughing up blood again like a lot
of blood like more than you're thinking
right now
okay I'm freaked out I see a friend
walking into the open mic I sort of flag
her down because I'm scared and I don't
want to be alone we get into a cab we go
to another hospital
the ER doctor tells me that unless I'm
coughing up like a
of blood it's not an emergency there's
nothing they can do for me it pretty
much feels like an emergency have you
ever seen ER doctor a character in a
movie coughing up blood they tend not to
make it but it is enough of a concern
that they make me wear a mask the whole
time so they don't want to get sick but
I don't know what's going on no one
knows what's going on Thursday afternoon
he sends me out into the streets of New
York to just cough up blood on my own
hey have a great weekend Friday June
16th my mom set up a couple doctor's
appointments for me in Manhattan the
first one an internist he tells me
there's a flesh-eating bacteria in my
lungs but that I'm pretty much okay and
I should just go about my life until we
can figure out what's going on I'm a
little reassured so between my first
appointment in my second I decided to go
back home to Brooklyn to pack a bag to
go and stay with my parents no I'm on
the train I feel that rattling in my
chest again I have a feeling that I'm
gonna start coughing up blood again but
because I'm polite I open up the doors
in between the train cars so I can cough
up blood onto the tracks
I keep coughing blood even as the train
pulls into the station so I get off the
train and I find a trash can on the
platform and I just post up no one stops
to help me or ask if I'm okay but I
don't blame them what would you do if
you saw someone coughing up blood it's
like more than the last time so each
time it's more and more blood when it's
over and I catch my breath I take a few
selfies cuz I'm a millennial and I call
my mom and I tell her I don't want to
die standing on the train platform she
tells me I'm not going to and I tell her
you can't say that you don't know that I
keep coughing up blood and everyone's
telling me I'm fine how was this fine I
go home I pack a bag and I make it to my
second doctor's appointment I had taken
a bunch of pictures on the train
platform to show to the doctors so I
show this doctor a bunch of pictures of
blood that I've coughed up and he's like
why are you showing me these pictures
I'm a doctor I know what blood looks
like he tells me we're gonna do a
procedure called a bronchoscopy and
they're gonna do it first thing Monday
why is medicine a nine-to-five coughing
up blood is 24/7 he tells me to go home
to my parents place so now for the third
time a medical professional has told me
to go home so I'm like lying on the
couch that day was the day that my
sister's boyfriend was planning on
coming over to my parents place to ask
for their blessing to propose to my
sister it's a great time everyone's
celebrating sipping wine eating cheese
meanwhile I'm lying on the couch
wondering whether or not I'm gonna die I
reach for the Brie and someone's like
hey maybe we could make a plate for him
so he doesn't have to touch the food
with his coughing up blood ass fingers
anyway party's over
I go to sleep about 2:00 a.m. I wake up
to another rattling feeling in my chest
I call for my parents my mom comes in
with a bowl and I just start coughing up
blood into this bowl and I don't stop
for like a while and I just keep
coughing up blood and my mom is there
with our hand on my back telling me it's
gonna be okay and I'm mad at her because
this doesn't feel okay when it's over
there's enough blood to fill up like
multiple bowls so now I understand you
can't tell your son that you don't know
if he's gonna die tonight and I'm
grateful that my parents were there for
me and were strong for me and put me at
ease because there wasn't really
anything to do the next morning I wake
up with a fever of a hundred and three
my parents call the doctor they tell us
it's time to go to the hospital they
admit me to the pulmonary ICU and I'm
like yes finally something is happening
they're at least taking this seriously
they just observed me that night
Saturday I stay in the hospital Sunday
afternoon there's a doctor talking to me
and my parents they've done another test
for tuberculosis it comes back positive
five minutes later I'm in the ER and
they decide to put me under general
anesthesia they send a thingy up through
my groin just try to stop the bleeding
but apparently the infection was so
advanced at that point so they
me in a coma and remove the infected
part of my lung four days later I wake
up from a medically induced coma the
doctors are going with tuberculosis when
I graduated from college I took a job
teaching English in China then I sort of
backpacked around Asia for about six
months after that the going theory is
that I picked up tuberculosis somewhere
in Asia and then it's at dormant in my
system for about four years the CDC has
basically declared me legally gross you
have to report tuberculosis because it
can be an epidemic so the doctors are
ready to release me on like a Friday
afternoon but the CDC has to approve my
release and they don't work on the
weekends go figure
and meanwhile by the way my family my
friends they're all visiting me everyone
has to wear masks I'm also grateful that
I was on my parent's insurance by the
way because having tuberculosis if you
have it like me can cost around like
three hundred thousand dollars so I know
a lot of people in my position wouldn't
have gotten the care that I got and
would be much worse off so I've got like
the weekend the CDC hasn't yet approved
my release one day I think it's a
Saturday I go to the bathroom I've got
my phone I've got the Wi-Fi password I'm
pretty stoked that I'm alive so I
decided to give myself some celebratory
me time and I forget that I have a
wireless heart monitor strapped to my
chest and the thing about wireless heart
monitors they can't tell the difference
between an orgasm and a heart attack so
the nurses come rushing and they're
banging on the door I'm like it's
occupied they're like we know this is
your hospital room I'm like I'm having a
bowel movement they're like okay I can't
believe I'm talking about off in a
BuzzFeed video Monday the CDC comes to
my room not only do they make me
basically promise to stay at home they
send a representative to come watch me
take pills every day
that's how serious this is I forgot to
mention that I was in the hospital
during my parents anniversary Father's
Day and my sister and her soon-to-be
fiance's housewarming party really
ruined a lot of good times for everyone
despite everything that happened that
summer was like the best son
of my life my sister did get engaged in
Italy I was there it was beautiful
I took an amazing bike trip with one of
my best friends in Montana right before
our other best friend's wedding I stood
by his side as he married the love of
his life and I looked super hot doing it
because here's the thing when you get
tuberculosis and you're in the hospital
for like two weeks you lose a bunch of
weight yeah I almost died but I also got
a lot of thirst traps out of it
[Music]